right around the time the president
lands in Hanoi his former personal
attorney and fixer Michael Cohen is due
to start testifying on Capitol Hill
think about that timing the source
confirms to CBS News that Cohen plans to
accuse the president of criminal conduct
in connection with hush money paid to
women who claimed they had sex with mr.
Trump more than a decade ago
Cohen reportedly will also reveal some
of the president's financial statements
and accuse him of making racist comments
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
it's gonna be a busy morning good
morning it is and a busy afternoon as
well Nora because it sounds like Cohen
could get grilled today the first of
three days of testimony for up to ten
hours and tomorrow we're told that he is
going to provide the House Oversight
Committee with documents that show that
the president may have engaged in tax
fraud today though he's going before the
Senate Intelligence Committee this is
the hearing that's going to be behind
closed doors they're looking into
Russian interference and senators are
not inclined to go easy on a man who
lied to Congress the last time he was
here this committee wants to know why he
misled them about president Trump's 2016
pursuit of a big Moscow real estate
project did someone tell him to lie how
many other Russia deals
did the president pursue stretching back
to the 1980s and who were his key
business partners there now Cohen has
been sentenced to three years in prison
he's set to be incarcerated in May and
he's been working with federal
prosecutors and looking for ways to get
his sentence reduced
so senators hope that that will give him
some incentive to be more truthful to
them this time bottom line Gail they
know that he is a flawed witness but he
is still one of the people who knows
Donald Trump's business background best
and a lot of people waiting hear what he
has to say thank you very much Nancy